it's just like old times but without the
royal titles
back on european soil together after two
years the duke and duchess of sussex
made a discreet visit to the invictus
games perhaps keen to not become the
main attraction but as they met
competitors it wasn't long before words
slowly spread
it was this moment that delighted the
unsuspecting crowd the most
[Applause]
prince harry clearly up for the
challenge as the duchess also enjoyed
the show
it's been a bumpy road for them since
quitting life as senior working royals
but the duke and duchess of sussex have
chosen to return to europe in the public
eye for a competition founded by the
prince himself and it's clear they've
been missed
the pair couldn't resist also hitching a
ride with these youngsters their
presence here is welcomed not only by
visitors but by competitors too
it's really great to see him on
on good form and and it's really good to
see him connect with with the guys you
know it's him it's it's him
harry the soldier connecting with
with the boys and girls and it's really
good to see
of the 17 nations present there's one
whose arrival is particularly remarkable
the ukrainian delegation made it through
a war zone to get here among the team is
anna her mother tara was due to compete
this week but the military paramedic has
gone missing in mariupol the 18 year old
hasn't heard from her in over a month
actually i came here to
tell him the truth about what happened
to my mother and
like
screaming about it
to the people uh
to
[Music]
just
for they know the situation in my
country and what happened to my mother
in the spirit of the games it's the sick
injured and wounded competitors from
ukraine and other conflicts will be
celebrated this week a message of
solidarity aptly delivered in the city
of peace and justice ashanaharanax 9
news in the hague